deux à trois heures c'est le temps qu'il
faut attendre pour se faire dépister
dans ce laboratoire d'analysés médicales
de neuilly-sur-seine laboratoire qui
procèdent tous les jours à 400 tests de
dépistage pourquoi est ce qu'il y à
autant de monde parce que de nombreux
laboratoires s'enfermer pendant ce mois
d'août mais également parce qu'on n'a
plus besoin d'ordonnancé plus besoin de
ressentir de quelconques symptômes liés
au kobus 19 pour se faire dépister
le test est obligatoire pour voyager
dans de nombreux pays comme l'allemagne
la tunisie mais également territoire
français dans les outre-mers obligatoire
également dans certains milieux
professionnels sportifs notamment est
nécessaire elle s'il en a été en contact
avec une personne contaminée par le
virus je vous propose d'écouter ces
quelques témoignages
je suis là pour passer un test comme
tout le monde
et oui là peut être longue et c'est à
toute heure il ya une queue folle donc
bon on est obligé de prendre son mal en
patience et attendre que ça fait deux
heures que j'attends pour faire un test
pourquoi je fais un test parce que j'ai
côtoyés quelqu'un qui a attrapé un virus
il ya une dizaine de jours et j'aurais
pu se vérifier
lundi dernier une salariée de notre
entreprise a été testé positif qu'on lui
a demandé de rentrer et suite à divers
discussions avec le chef d'entreprise et
des médecins ils nous ont conseillé à
toutes les personnes qui l'ont croisé de
venir faire un test pcr
bah ça fait une heure maintenant que
j'attends et puis bah je le passe parce
que je voyage d'ici trois jours je vais
en côte d'ivoire et donc du coup je suis
obligé de passer par le test du coc vide
donc j'ai fait comme tout le monde
ils veulent passer en 72 heures le
dépistage pratiqué ici et le tests
virologiques appelée pcr avec
prélèvement nasopharyngé il faut
attendre 24 à 48 heures pour avoir les
résultats des tests entièrement prise en
charge par la sécurité sociale
dans l'attenté d'un vaccin le tester la
solution la plus efficace pour lutter
contre la propagation du virus
si une personne est en effet testée
positive elle devra être isolé et son
entourage tester à son tour